[موسيقى]
بعد حوالي 12 يوم من انطلاق عمليه طوفان
الاقصى اللي شنتها كتائب عز الدين القسام
على الكيان المحتل وتحديدا يوم 19 اكتوبر
اللي فات قررت جماعه انصار الله او
الحوثييين اليمنيه الانخراط في المعركه ضد
اسرائيل كرد فعل على الحرب الوحشيه اللي
بيشن الكيان المحتل على اهلنا في قطاع غزه
هنروح جنوب البحر الاحمر وتحديدا هنا اللي
قدامنا دي اليمن جماعه الحوثيين بيسيطر
على الشمال الغربي اليمني كله المسافه من
المنطقه اللي بيسيطر عليها الحوثيين دي
وقلب الاراضي المحتله حوالي 2200 كل في 19
اكتوبر ضرب الحوثيين ثلاث صواريخ كروز
واطلقوا ثمان طيارات بدون طيار اتجهت
شمالا على طول البحر الاحمر باتجاه اهداف
اسرائيليه في الاراضي المحتله في الوقت ده
كانت المدمره الامريكيه يو اس اس كارني
وصلت من البحر المتوسط لشمال البحر الاحمر
قبلها بيومين فقدرت تسقط الصواريخ
والطيارات المصيره قبل ما توصل لاهدافها
بعدها ولحد اواخر اكتوبر توالت هجمات
الحوثيين بعدد كبير من الصواريخ البالستيه
متوسطه المدى اللي اسمها بركان ثلاثه
وبالطو وده دفع جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
انه يشغل لاول مره منظومه الدفاع الصاروخي
بعيد المدى ار 3 لاسقاط الصواريخ دي مع
اعتراض القطع البحريه الامريكيه في البحر
الاحمر لجزء منها برده لو رجعنا للخريطه
ثاني ورحنا للمنطقه اللي بيسيطر عليها
الحوثيين في الشمال الغربي من اليمن
هنلاقيهم بيمتلك ميزه استراتيجيه خطيره
جدا وهو قربهم من مضيق باب المندب اللي
بيربط المحيط الهندي بالبحر الاحمر وقناه
السويس زي ما احنا شايفين عرض المضيق 30 م
بس بعد اسابيع من انطلاق اولى هجماتهم ضد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الحوثيين قرروا تغيير
استراتيجيه الهجوم وبداوا اعتبارا من
منتصف نوفمبر في استهداف السفن التجاريه
اللي بتعدي من مضيق باب المندا ومع قربهم
الشديد من بوابه البحر الاحمر دي
وامتلاكهم لترسانه ضخمه من الصواريخ
البالستيه المضاده للسفن والعدد كبير من
الطيارات المصيره فهم قادرين على الوصول
بسهوله لاي فينه بتعدي من المضيق سواء
ضربها بالصواريخ او الصعود على متنها
بالزوارق الصغيره او الهبوط فوقها
بالمروحيات وعلشان كده اعلنوا استهداف
السفن التجاريه المرتبطه باسرائيل في
محاوله للتاثير على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
وده اللي حصل بالفعل اقتصاد الاحتلال اللي
بيعتمد بشكل كاسح على التجاره البحريه
اصبح شبه محاصر بعد ما موانين رئيسيه بقت
في مرمى نيران الحوثيين من ناحيه
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه من ناحيه انيه وده
خلى شركات شحن كبيره تخاف من انها تقرب من
اغلب الموانئ الاسرائيليه وبالاخص ميناء
ايلات الموجود على البحر الاحمر وميناء
عسقلان الموجود على البحر المتوسط والقريب
جدا من حدود قطاع غزه ولكن هجمات الحوثيين
على السفن المرتبطه بالاحتلال الاسرائيلي
او المتجه ناحيته واللي وصل عددها وفقا
للقياده المركزيه الامريكيه اللي بتشرف
على العمليات العسكريه في الشرق الاوسط ال
24 هجوم في الفتره ما بين 19 نوفمبر و3
يناير ماثرتش بس على الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وانما كمان كان لها تاثيرات على الاقتصاد
العالمي كله اللي بيحصل في البحر الاحمر
اتسبب في حاله من الخوف اثرت على سلاسل
التوريد العالميه وعملت اكبر اضطراب
للتجاره العالميه وصناعه الشحن البحري من
ايام وباء كورونا مش عارف حضراتكم تعرفوا
ولا لا بس وسيله النقل الرئيسيه للتجاره
العالميه هي الشحن عبر المحيطات وحوالي
90% من التجاره العالميه بتتحرك عن طريق
البحر علشان كده في حلقه النهارده
النهارده المهمه جدا هنعرف ايه اللي بيحصل
بالظبط في البحر الاحمر وهنشرح تبعات
هجمات الحوثيين على كل الاطراف وازاي اثرت
مثلا على قناه السويس وايه اهميه القناه
الاستراتيجيه في سلاسل الامداد العالميه
وهنعرف تاثير هجوم الحوثيين على عملقه
الشحن في العالم وتكلفه تغيير مسارات
الرحلات البحريه من البحر الاحمر لطريق
راس الرجاء الصالح جنوب القاره الافريقيه
حلقه مهمه جدا جدا لازم تشوفوها للاخر انا
اشرف ابراهيم ده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي الحلقه دي برعايه شركه سيروس
ماركتس وهي شركه وساطه ماليه مرخصه من قبل
اف اس ايه الشركه مقرها الرئيسي في
ماليزيا وموجوده في اسواق الخليج العربي
وهي الوسيط العالمي الوحيد اللي بيسمح
بتداول العملات المشفره مقابل اي فئه من
الاصول زي الاسهم والسلع والمؤشرات سيروس
ماركت بيقدموا رافعه ماليه بتوصل لواحد ل
400 ولهم حسابات منفصله في احد البنوك من
المستوى الاول لو عايز تتداول معاهم ادرس
كويس مخاطر الاستثمار واقرا اكث عن الشركه
وهتلاقي رابط تحت الفيديو هيديلك مكافئه
ايداع 100% لو سجلت من خلاله قبل ما نبص
على الاضطرابات في البحر الاحمر ونحلل
اللي بيعمله الحوثيين لازم نبص سريعا على
قناه بانما في امريكا الوسطى الممر
الملاحي المنافس لقناه السويس قناه بانما
هي ممر ماء اصطناعي طوله حوالي 82 كم
وبيربي بين المحيطين الاطلسي والهادي هو
طريق مختصر للسفن بين شرق اسيا والساحل
الشرقي للولايات المتحده ومقارنه بقناه
السويس مثلا فقناه بانما بتختصر خمس ايام
من زمن الرحلات بين نيويورك وشانغهاي
للسفن اللي بتسافر بسرعه متوسطه وهي
بتتعامل مع حوالي 5% من التجاره البحريه
في العالم وبالتالي هي مهمه للتجاره
العالميه وبالذات في تسهيل نقل الوقود
والحبوب الامريكيه متجهه لاسيا وهي
بالمناسبه اكبر مصدر للدخل البنامين يعني
في 2022 مثلا حققت لدوله بانما 4.3 مليار
دولار ليه كل ده اصبح مهدد وايه مشكله
قناه بانما اللي بقى لها كا شهر وواضح
انها مكمله معانا شويه شهر اكتوبر اللي
فات كان هو الاكثر جفافا في منطقه قناه
بانما من سنه 1950 على الاقل بسبب ظاهره
النينو المناخيه اللي اثرت على ه طول
الامتار ودرجات الحراره على مستوى العالم
للي ما يعرفش من حضراتكم الفرق بين قناه
السويس وقناه بانما ان قناه السويس هي
قناه على مستوى سطح البحر ولكن قناه بانما
هي قناه للمياه العزبه معتمده على بحيرات
صناعيه وده بيخليها معرضه للجفاف وبالتالي
مياه الامتار ضروريه لتشغيل القناه لانها
بتقع على ارتفاع 26 متر فوق سطح البحر
وشغاله بنظام الاقفال اللي بترفع السفن
علشان تقدر تدخل وتخرج المهم لما قناه
بانما بتكون شغاله بطاقتها القصوى فممكن
يمر من القناه ما بين 38 ل 40 سفينه في
اليوم ولكن خلال الشهور اللي فاتت وبسبب
انخفاض منسوب المياه عدد السفن ده قل جدا
ووصل ل 2 سفينه وقت تصوير الحلقه وهين خفض
ل 18 سفينه بس اعتبارا من شهر فبراير
الجاي انخفاض اعداد السفن اللي هيسمح لها
بالمرور من قناه بانما وانخفاض حمولتها
وارتفاع رسوم المرور بسبب مزايده على
الحجوزات خلى شركات الشحنه العالميه تبدا
تغير مسار حلاتها البحريه لقناه السويس زي
مثلا مجموعه هاب جلويد الالمانيه اللي هي
خامس اكبر مالك لسفن الحاويات عالميا لما
اعلنت عن تحويل ما لا يقل عن 42 سفينه
تابعه ليها من قناه بانما لقناه سويس
مشكله الجفاف في قناه بانما مطوله معانا
شويه وكانت هتبقى بمثابت هديه ثمينه جدا
لقناه السويس وكانت هتعمل انتعاشه قويه في
ايراداتها لكن في نفس الوقت بدات هجمات
الحوثيين على السفن التجاريه اللي بتعدي
عبر مضيق باب المن فبمجرد ما تنتهي هجمات
الحوثيين هتقدر قناه السويس تستفيد بشكل
كبير من ازمه قناه بانما ولو عاوزنا نعمل
حلقه خاصه نوضح فيها المشكله الكبيره اللي
بتواجه قناه بانما وازاي بيفكروا يحلوها
وتاثير ده على قناه السويس وطرق الملاحه
العالميه يا ريت تعرفوني في
التعليقات نطلع بقى من قناه بانما ونروح
لمكان حلقتنا الاساسي منطقه البحر الاحمر
وتاثير هجمات الحوثيين هناك واللي ممكن
نقسمها لتاثيرات مقصوده وتاثيرات غير
مقصوده بالنسبه للتاثيرات المقصوده فزي ما
قلنا الحوثيين وضحوا انهم
هيستهلك الاسرائيليه او اللي هتروح لاي
ميناء في اسرائيل بهدف حصار اقتصاد
الاحتلال وبالتالي اجباره على وقف عدوانه
الوحشي على قطاع غزه طبعا لما نعرف ان
99% من البضايع اللي الكيان المحتل
بيستورد بتيجي عن طريق البحر وان 30% من
الواردات الاسرائيليه دي بتمر عبر البحر
الاحمر على سفن الحاويات
هنتاكس على السفن المرتبطه باسرائيل مؤثره
ومؤلمه لاقتصاد الاحتلال بحسب بيانات
المكتب المركزي للاحصاء في اسرائيل في شهر
اكتوبر اللي فات بلغ اجمال الواردات
الاسرائيليه من السلع باستثناء الماس 17.5
مليار شيكل 25 في من الواردات دي كانت
جايه من دول اسيويه وكانت بتشمل الات
لازمه لمشاريع البنيه التحتيه والبناء
ومنتجات استهلاكيه ومنتجات الكترونيه
وبضائع مطلوبه من المواقع الصينيه زي علي
اكسبرس بالتالي الشحن البحري يعتبر شريان
حياه لاقتصاد الكيان المحتل مش للواردات
بس ولكن لصادرات و كمان لان اسيا هي ثاني
شريك تجاري للاسرائيليين بعد اوروبا علشان
كده رون مالكا الرئيس التنفيذي لميناء
حيفا بيقول لرويترز ان الموانئ هي اكسجين
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي ولكن كتا فيير عرضي
او غير مقصود هجمات الحوثيين ماثرتش على
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي بس ولكن على تدفق
البضائع وحركه التجاره العالميه في كل
مكان بيستخدم الممر الملاحي الرئيسي ده
وعلشان حضراتكم تكونوا عارفين اهميه
وخطوره المنطقه دي محتاجين نعرف حجم
التجاره العالميه اللي بتمر من خلالها
وبتطلع منين وبتروح لمين بالظبط مضيق باب
دب هو الطريق الوحيد المؤدي لقناه السويس
وبالتالي فهو بيربط اكبر مستهلك السلع
القابله للتداول في الشرق الاوسط واوروبا
والولايات المتحده مع كبار المعرضين في
اسيا واهميته زادت اكث بعد مشكله قناه
بانما زي ما وضحنا وبالتالي بقى البديل
المباشر لمرور السلع من شرق اسيا لشرق
الولايات المتحده شركه دريات جلوبال
بريطانيه لاستشارات المخاطر البحريه
والامن بتقول ان 35000 سفينه بتبح عبر
منطقه البحر الاحمر سنويا وبتنقل البضايع
بين اوروبا والشرق الاوسط واسيا وده بيمثل
حوالي 10% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
العالمي قناه السويس اللي طولها 192 كم
وبتعتبر اسرع طريق بحري بين اسيا واوروبا
وواحده من اكثر طرق التجاره ازدحاما في
العالم بيمر منها 12% من حجم التجاره
العالميه بما في ذلك 30% من حركه الحاويات
في العالم و ده بيمثل اكث من ترليون دولار
من البضايع سنويه على سبيل المثال فالحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا والعقوبات الاوروبيه
على روسيا خلت قناه السويس والبحر الاحمر
ممر تجاري عالمي حيوي للنفط اوروبا مثلا
بعد ما وقفت شراء النفط من روسيا بدات
تعتمد على الشحنات القادمه من الشرق
الاوسط ومعظمها بيمر شمالا من قناه السويس
روسيا على الناحيه الثانيه بدات تبيع
النفط بتاعها للهند والصين وجزء كبير منه
بيتش شاحن من موانئ بحر الشمال والبحر
الاسود وبيمر جنوبا من قناه السويس برده
التطور ده ادى لزياده حركه مرور النفط عبر
البحر الاحمر شمالا وجنوبا بحوالي 140%
ووصلت ل 3.8 مليون برميل يوميه ده بالنسبه
للنفط اما عن الغاز ف 88% من تجاره الغاز
الطبيعي المثال في العالم بتمر عبر البحر
الاحمر و 88% من تجاره الحبوب العالميه
بتمر من نفس الطريق يعني بنتكلم تقريبا في
حوالي 80 مليون طن من الحبوب بتمر كل سنه
من قناه السويس للتهم بالمناسبه بيروح
للصين وبسبب دورها المحوري في تدفق
التجاره العالميه فقناه السويس تعتبر مصدر
مهم وحيوي للاقتصاد المصري رسوم القناه هي
احد المصادر الرئيسيه للعمله الصعبه في
السنه الماليه 22 23 حققت قناه السويس
ايرادات وصلت لمستوى قياسي بلغ 9.4 مليار
دولار مع مرور اكثر من 2 20 ال سفينه على
مدار السنه ولكن بعد سلسله الهجمات اللي
استهدف فيها الحوثيين السفن التجاريه
اعلنت شركات الشحن العالميه ايقاف رحلاتها
عبر البحر الاحمر وتحويل مسار السفن لطريق
راس الرجاء الصالح جنوب القاره الافريقيه
تجنبا للخطر على سبيل المثال اكبر ثمان
شركات شحن حويات في العالم واللي قدامكم
على الشاشه
ومتوعدا واسيا اعلنوا تحويل مسار سفنهم من
البحر الاحمر لطريق راس رجاء الصالح ومش
هم بس وانما غيرهم من شركات شحن الحاويات
وشركات تجاره السلع الاوليه العالميه لو
دخلنا على الموقع الالكتروني لشركه ميرسك
مثلا علشان نشوف مسارات السفن اللي هتبحث
ابيع الجايه هنلاقي الشركه حولت مسار جميع
السفن اللي كان مقرر انها تعبر البحر
الاحمر وخليج عدن لطريق راس الرجاء الصالح
عمالقه النفط والغاز بي بي البريطانيه
واكو انور النرويجيه اعلنوا برده ايقاف
عبور جميع الشحنات بتاعتهم المنطقه علشان
كده لو جينا عملنا تتبع لحركه السفن هناك
هنلاحظ بسهوله السفن اللي بدات تغير
مساراتها وبدلا من الدخول من مضيق باب
المندب هنلاقيها بتختار الطريق الاطول
والاكثر تكلفه هو طريق راس رجاء الصالح
جنوب القاره الافريقيه لتجنب خطر هجوم
الحوثيين زي ما احنا شايفين حركه السفن
بشكل مباشر وقت تصوير الحلقه 7 يناير طب
كم عدد السفن اللي غيرت وجهت من البحر
الاحمر لراس الرجاء الصالح وفقا لاحدث
بيانات قدرنا نحصل عليها من شركه الخدمات
اللوجستيه السوسريه العملاقه كونان نيجل
انترناشونال اي جي وقبل تصوير الحلقه
مباشره فعدد السفن اللي تاثرت بالوضع
وقررت تغير رحلتها حتى يوم 5 يناير هو 420
سفينه هم اللي موجودين على الخريطه قدامنا
زي ما احنا شايفين واضح الازدحام اللي
حوالين طريق راس رجاء الصالح طبعا كل
سفينه من دول نقدر نحدد تفاصيلها وحجم
حمولتها وجايه منين ورايحه فين وشايله ايه
وبالتالي هجمات الحوثيين تسببت في تعطل
تدفق البضائع في احد اهم الممرات الملاحيه
في العالم هو البحر الاحمر وده بيعطل
سلاسل التوريد العالميه وبشكل ضربه مفاجاه
للاقتصاد العالمي في السنه الجديده
2024 وهنا يجي سؤال مهم ورئيسي ازاي هجمات
الحوثيين ممكن تكون بتاثر على الاقتصاد
العالمي علشان نجاوب على السؤال ده
محتاجين نبص على الخريطه ثاني لو عندنا
سفينه هتطلع من ميناء سنغافوره في جنوب
شرق اسيا ورايح اكبر ميناء بحري في اوروبا
مثلا هو ميناء روتردام في هولندا المفروض
الطريق الطبيعي بتاع السفينه دي انها تسلك
الممر الملاحي في البحر الاحمر وتعدي من
قناه السويس
وهتستفيد دي لو اضطرت تمشي جنوبا من طريق
راس الرجاء الصالح هتستغرب في احسن
الاحوال سته 30 يوم في الرحله دي وبالتالي
طريق راس الرجاء الصالح بيضيف وقت من 10 ل
14 يوم زياده للرحله مقارنه بطريق قناه
السويس فين المشكله هنا برض المشكله ان
ابحار سفن الشحن في عرض البحر لايام زياده
بيكلف ملايين الدولارات انتم عارفين يا
اخوانا حركه اعاده توجيه السفينه لطريق
راس رجاء الصالح بدل من قناه سويس بيكلف
السفينه وقود اضافي لكل رحله ذهابا وايابا
بين اسيا واوروبا كام مليون دولار ايوه زي
ما حضراتكم سمعتوا كده ده غير تكلفه تعطيل
سلاسل التوريد لان السفن هتوصل لوجهتها في
وقت متاخر من المتوقع
وهتستفيد هي احد اسباب الارتفاع الكبير
دلوقتي في اسعار شحن الحاويات الفوريه
سبوت كونتينر شيبنج بين اسيا واوروبا
والولايات المتحده والسبب الان ثاني
لارتفاع اسعار الحاويات هو زياده طاقه
شركات الشحن لما الرحله بقت تاخد وقت اطول
فده ادى لتقليل عرض السفن وهنا خطوط الشحن
بترفع اسعارها وفقا لشركه فريتوس وهي منصه
لحجز ودفع الشحن الدولي فالسعر الفوري
لشحن البضايع في حاويه بطول 40 قدم من
اسيا لشمال اوروبا تجاوز في 3 يناير ال
4000 دولار وده معناه ان الاسعار قفزت
بنسبه 173 في من منتصف ديسمبر بعد تغيير
مسار السفر ومتوقع ان الاسعار دي تزيد
كمان يعني مثلا مجموعه الشحن الفرنسيه سي
ام اي اعلنت يوم 2 يناير في بيان نشرته
على موقعها انها هتزود اسعار شحن الحويات
بتاعتها من اسيا لمنطقه البحر المتوسط
بنسبه 100% من 3000 دولار ل 6000 دولار
للحاويه الواحده اللي طولها 40 قدم بين
اسيا وغرب البحر المتوسط مثلا والزياده
ديت مطبق من يوم 15 يناير اسعار الشحن ما
كانتش هي الحاجه الوحيده اللي زادت ولكن
تكاليف التامين على السفن اللي هتعبر
البحر الاحمر مره ثانيه هي كمان زادت بشكل
حاد بسبب المخاطر العاليه في المنطقه يوم
18 ديسمبر اللي فات شركات التامين البحري
في لندن وسعت المناطق داخل البحر الاحمر
اللي بيصنعها عاليه المخاطر تكلفه التامين
للسفينه الواحده ارتفعت 10 اضعاف مقارنه
باول للشهر نفسه علشان حضراتكم تكونوا في
الصوره التامين ضد مخاطر الحرب عموما بيتم
تحديده كنسبه مئويه من قيمه بدن السفينه
خلال الفتره اللي السفينه هتبحث الخطره
وتغطيه التامين الاضافي ده عاده بيكون
لفتره مدتها سبع ايام ده معناه ايه يا
اخوانا برده معناه ان لو سفينه قيمتها 100
مليون دولار مثلا فالتامن بتاعها هيكون
700000 دولار للرحله الواحده استهلا لاك
الوقود الكبير بسبب طول المسافه وارتفاع
اسعار الحاويات وزياده تكاليف اقساط
التامين هتدي ببساطه لارتفاع اسعار السلع
المنقوله بحر وبالتالي تجار التجزئه
والمصنعين هيمر التكاليف المرتفعه دي
للمستهلكين في الاخر على كل السلع بدءا من
الاحذيه الرياضيه والطعام ومرورا
بالسيارات ووصولا للنفط وده هيؤدى ازياده
معدل التضخم في العالم كله وبالتالي هياثر
على تكاليف في المعيشه وده بيشكل مخاطر
كبيره على الاقتصاد العالمي في الوقت اللي
يادوب كان التضخم بدا ينخفض فيه في العالم
لو ركزنا على اوروبا مثلا ففي مخاوف كبيره
من انقطاع تدفقات الطاقه في وقت بتعتمد
فيه بشكل متزايد على الغاز المنقول بحرا
علشان يحل محل غاز خطوط الانابيب الروسي
وبالتالي متوقع ان اسعار الوقود والبضائع
المتجهه لاوروبا تشهد ارتفاع كبير عملاق
الاثاث السويدي شركه ايكيا مثلا قالت انها
بتدور على خيارات ثانيه علشان تقدر توفر
منتجاتها بعد ما شركات الشحن اللي شايله
منتجاتها قررت اعاده توجيه السفن بعيدا عن
البحر الاحمر و كده بالمناسبه جزء كبير من
منتجاتها بيمر عبر البحر الاحمر وقناه
السويس جاي من مصانعها في اسيا وبيروح
اسواقها في الشرق الاوسط واوروبا
والولايات المتحده عمالقه تجاره التجزئه
في الولايات المتحده زي و مارت وتارجت
وميسي ونايكي بيعتمدوا على طريق البحر
الاحمر وقناه السويس علشان يحصلوا على
البضايع بتاعتهم من الهند والصين
وسريلانكا شركه بيع الملابس بالتجزئه ابر
كرومبي ان فيتش الامريكيه مثلا بدات
تستبدل الشحن البحري بالشحن الجوي لتجنب
الاضطرابات وتاخير توافر المنتجات وده
خيار مكلف جدا طبعا لان الشركات اللي
بتتعامل مع سله حرجه او ذات قيمه عاليه زي
الملابس المصممه والالكترونيات والمواد
الطبيه وبتضل تتحول للشحن الجوي التكاليف
عليها بتكون اكبر بكثير من الشحن البحري
لان الشحن الجوي بيكلف ما يقرب من 5 ل 15
مره اكثر من النقل البحري الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يمكن هو اكبر متضرر من الحاصل
حاليا في البحر الاحمر ولكنه بالتاكيد مش
المتضرر الوحيد لانه على الرغم من ان
الهدف المعلن لهجمات الحوثيين هو السفن
المرتبطه بالاسرائيليين الا ان ده ما
يمنعش ان في حاله من الخوف والقلق عند كل
شركات الشحن اللي بتعدي من البحر الاحمر
في السياق ده الاحتلال الاسرائيلي استنجد
كالعاده بماما امريكا وبعدد من حلفائه في
اوروبا وعلى راسهم المانيا علشان يحطوا حد
لهجمات الحوثيين وده
بذريعة الرئيسي ده من هجمات الحوثيين ورغم
تشكيل القوى العسكريه الضخمه دي الا انها
ما نجحتش في ايقاف هجمات الحوثيين على
السفن التجاريه اللي فضلت مستمره لحد لحظه
تصوير الحلقه وبالتالي ما قدرتش تقنع
شركات الشحن العالميه باستئناف العبور من
البحر الاحمر علشان كده في 3 يناير اصدرت
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وحلفاء تانيين
تحذير اخير لجماعه الحوثيين لوقف هجماتهم
والي حيت تم توجيه ضربه عسكريه ليهم على
الناحيه الثانيه الحوثيين توعدوا قبل كده
انهم لن يتوقفوا عن هجماتهم على السفن
التجاريه التابعه لاسرائيل حتى ايقاف
العدوان على قطاع غزه طبعا الوضع بيتطور
بسرعه كبيره يعني ممكن جدا وحضرتك بتتفرج
عل دلوقتي يكون تم توجيه ضربه عسكريه
للحوثيين بالفعل او قرر الكيان المحتل وقف
عدوان الوحش على قطاع غزه او الصراع نفسه
وسع ودخل فيه جماعات ودول ثانيه الله الله
اعلم باللي هيحصل ولكن بعيدا عن ده الواحد
فعلا مستغرب هو مش اسهل لامريكا والغرب
انهم يضغطوا على الكيان الزفر لوقف عدوانه
على غزه بعد ثلاث شهور من الحرب الدمويه
اللي قتلوا فيها حوالي 23000 فلسطيني
واصابوا 60,000 ثانيين وسووا القطاع
بالارض مش كفايه كده يعني تحالف عسكري
وحاملات طائرات وخساير بمليارات الدولارات
للاقتصاد العالمي علشان يوقفوا هجمات
الحوثيين ومش قادرين او مش عاوزين يجبروا
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على ايقاف حربه
الدمويه دي لا تعليق فعلا في النهايه
بتمنى ان العدوان الاسرائيلي المجرم على
قطاع غزه يتوقف باسرع وقت ممكن وان العالم
يكون عنده حد ادنى من الانصاف والعداله
بحيث يتم محاسبه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على
الجرايم اللي ارتكبها في حق اهالينا هناك
ما تنسوش تشوفوا شركه سيروس ماركتس
هتلاقوا رابط ليهم تحت الفيديو في النهايه
الليت لعبتوا الحلقه وحابين تشوفونا
اشتركوا في القناه واستنونا في حلقات
جديده باذن الله
[موسيقى]
سلام